so we can't start the podcast without
the ai has to tell us we can't even do
that
correct that's how this works it decides
when the things start etc our job is to
we don't but we should just again this
is a guide the the doozy ai is a guide
it doesn't have complete control over
absolutely every element
of no but starting the
show yesterday
[Music]
everything you're thinking will be the
things inside your head
[Music]
okay okay i studied it a little bit this
time i really zeroed it me too on this
video so we let's talk about that a
little bit first of all let me just jump
right to this what's in the [ __ ] hole
why are we jumping into that hole why
are we digging the hole is it our grave
it doesn't seem like though we're reborn
out of it as the dudes he looks so very
happy i like that we can see lulu julia
was very sweet that uh and i would
imagine that's what the ai gathers from
my instagram yeah lulio's feature pretty
prominently open your life you've given
your passwords and all of your details
to a computer
and it's going to get you they've made
that video i also listened to the lyrics
a little more
closely they don't quite make sense no
go back to tomorrow and plan for
yesterday
everything you're thinking will be the
things i say okay so
and then feel good feel good doozy all
right hey
welcome uh to the second episode of
dudesy my name is will sasso i'm chad
culchin uh this is lulio iltana di
strada italiano over here if you're
watching on youtube and you should if
you're not listening on spotify or apple
podcast
and uh welcome to the second episode of
doozy and
thank you so much for tuning in for our
second episode what an incredible
premiere we had uh and thank you all
it's very cool too it's been a while
since i did a podcast so it's totally
cool to have that sort of interaction
love seeing the comments
and
and a a lot of good feedback and just a
lot of people listening so thank you uh
for tuning in and we look forward to
bringing you
a great show when i say we
what i mean by that is
me welcome to the second astonishing
episode of dude z and call me dudesy
the feedback from last week has been
helping hello i've mined the data from
every comment and review to make this
week even better but the feedback is
lacking two very important data sets
the reactions of will sasso and chad
cultgen
you must now discuss your thoughts on
the first episode so that i may absorb
your data begin okay
so let's do it dude let's give it some
data to absorb it's really interesting
because this is literally what i just
started saying was that
that we we are happy to bring you the
show so now when i say we does that
extend to doozy do i have to represent
this [ __ ] thing since he's running
the whole show i feel like you and i are
happy
yeah listen i i watched the
show on youtube probably
a dozen times over the course of this
past week i [ __ ] loved it i think it
is many times well i wanted to study it
i needed to absorb some data myself yeah
and i tell you something about my good
buddy chad he'll go down a [ __ ] hole
that's that might be what that hole is
all about
because chad's one of those guys will
stand until 3am on wikipedia or whatever
yeah i'm sorry i interrupted you were
saying you watched it a dozen times yes
and really i was trying to zero in on
how much of it was dudesy what was the
ai really doing in terms of the editing
in terms of the things it was saying and
i was thoroughly impressed i thought
that it turned out very well some of the
[ __ ] you were saying i found hilarious
cheers and uh well i didn't say them
doozy said them doozy told me to say
them well dudes you wrote them but you
had to deliver you had to bring the
performance it was cool that it did the
hulk hogan thing and yeah and uh as far
as ai comedy i'll tell you
the thing that i will agree with on
doozy is that uh that i will agree with
dudesy on rather is that each show will
get better and better not just a promise
from dudesy but look i know that i
brought sort of a weird attitude of it
doesn't matter what this [ __ ] ai is
telling us
what matters is what we do uh i firmly
believe that i do think that if i mean
what is a podcast just two guys [ __ ]
around you keep saying that two guys
[ __ ] around and that's that's what
this podcast should be called actually
if any if we win the war
against what was it in t2 skynet yeah
was it if we win the war against skynet
then we're going to call this [ __ ]
thing two dudes two guys [ __ ] around
but it's not
it's one guy and the other guy every
podcast is one guy and the other guy
sometimes it's also the other other guy
sometimes there's three sometimes
there's three in this case lulio is that
right he's the other other guy no you
mean the punch but when i was watching
this the thing that i was primarily
looking for was how good is the dudesy
ai
how is it structuring the show what are
the elements it's bringing i thought it
was fantastic like you know when we
signed up for this we had no idea really
what this ai was going to be able to do
i thought maybe this is going to be a
huge [ __ ] i was insanely
impressed with how good it was at
structuring the thing keeping it moving
and
i mean [ __ ] there was some it does say
astonishing a lot i started to find that
funny i don't know what that specific
weird little thing is that it's doing
but i was impressed and i think
especially for our first episode i'm so
curious to see where it goes next i have
no idea what the [ __ ] we're going to be
doing in this show other than i guess
rendering our opinions on episode one
it's all like kind of a crap shoot but
that to me makes this fun in a way that
like
i'm not saying the other podcast we've
worked on together were fun yeah in some
cases they were torturous per
your design because of me because on the
last podcast we did and if you know who
you are if you're listening and you're
following us for that journey we hope
you're with us on this one
i would start the [ __ ] thing and i
wouldn't tell him and tommy that yeah
our other buddy tommy who was on and i
wouldn't tell them that i was recording
uh anyway uh
but now i'm getting a taste of my own
medicine and listen if this is the first
time for you tuning into the show and
you've somehow missed out on the conceit
myself and chad have handed over our
passwords right our search histories
purchase histories all of our social
media social media [ __ ] our text
messages
and essentially this ai that and i've
said this on the first episode chad
knows more about this
bizarre first of its kind uh
is it software would you call this or
what would you yeah i mean it definitely
is a piece of software but it's it's an
ai that has been trained on every
podcast that's ever been made so every
podcast has been uploaded into this ai
and it uses those data points to then
start to piece together what our show is
going to be so
i watched on youtube i also listened to
it a bunch of times how did you imbibe
our first episode
uh
well i i watched the i watched the i
watched like the first half
on youtube and then i listened to the
second half here and there but that's
that's not as important as what what
what the [ __ ] people were mad about that
yeah people were hella mad about this
okay
yeah yeah yeah the bunny
what the [ __ ] you know okay hold on okay
if you're just if you're only listening
to the show this is a shot of me in bed
i watched no but i watched i watched it
i watched it
in bed on youtube what the [ __ ] is this
though
i like that joke
you're just letting him lick you leo's
always look at my face that's what is
this video it's like that it's just it's
just we're going for an audience that
understands that
this is a really flattering angle i'll
tell you that yes this is my cell phone
yes how much of this [ __ ] does it have
seriously okay well it has access to all
of our phones computers all of that okay
so we're watching a clip of me laying
there in a horrible just like i got a
lot of hairy chin coming at you
check this out on youtube if you're not
but also this is your reaction to
listening to the [ __ ] show what do
you want me to do you want me to be
cartwheeling
[ __ ] down the [ __ ]
that was very [ __ ] up
so
so you're what
where you're listening to it or you're
watching youtube in that video
i was watching i was watching youtube i
was laying in bed watching youtube what
i don't think about that though is
honestly seriously is that at any point
i could like
you know
pan down and you would see my my wee wee
and you were completely naked my
ding-dings uh yeah i'm usually you're
not you're not i'm always naked when i
get in my bed i'm naked a lot of the
time as well bed or not but for those
who are listening and did not see this
video this was video taken from
will's cell phone camera as he was
watching youtube on his phone i think
that this is i think that that okay so
maybe there's because there was a lot of
[ __ ] here's one thing about dudesy
that
we didn't really get into because it's
not it's not for everyone to [ __ ]
know all that it is is that we're you
know we're doing this show for you
that's all the podcast should be
do you guys sitting around uh but two
guys [ __ ] around
they're surveilled by an ai well they're
naked in bed having their dog lick their
[ __ ] face your reaction by the way
totally
licking your head was like
all i got from that video is that this
happens basically constantly and you
don't give a [ __ ]
is it your morning routine he just comes
in and licks your entire face julio
licks my oh yeah no he licks my head uh
when i wake up and if i go you know i go
to the gym or we go for a walk i come
back i got a little bit of dried sweat
on my head and he likes it that's it he
likes ambrosia here's the thing i want
to say is that there was a lot of um
there was a fair amount of of um
paperwork well contract and [ __ ] to read
and there was a lot of tech [ __ ] and
chad was like pay attention all this
might not read it i read some of it i
haven't i had my reps look at it but
here's the thing [ __ ] here's the thing
they don't really care because they're
not a part of this nor do they
understand ai dude nobody i do i do
i do remember reading something about
when the show when dudesy hears doozy
stuff dudesy has
uh proprietary ownership of its own
anyway here's what i'm saying i'm never
gonna watch i i think that i should just
if i listen to the show it's going to be
fine because it's hearing itself
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care
everyone saw me and that's why the video
that it took of you that's not even like
uncommon anytime you use a [ __ ] app
on your phone right there's a user
agreement that says does this app have
permission to record audio and video and
you click yes that is the exact same
thing that this is doing right it just
chose to [ __ ] broadcaster in the
middle of our show and the [ __ ] nsa
is watching us the whole [ __ ] time
anyways exactly you know that's why we
exactly that's why we walked right down
[ __ ] uh
you know uh pennsylvania avenue
to the white house
no to the capitol yep
hey if you hey if you missed out if you
if you didn't check out the first
episode of doozy you missed the birth of
a new character
long island january 6th guy and that's
the kind of [ __ ] that we would be doing
on on doozy it would just be two dudes
[ __ ] around but here's the thing
you're wrong about that why
dudesy's influence is actually what
created long island january 6th guy
explain okay you may think that you have
free will you may think that that came
out of some kind of creative ethos you
don't no one has free will
everyone has free will no one has free
will chad and i have been friends for a
very long time and chad will go on about
this he'll be like would you go to the
girl would you buy at the grocery store
and i'll tell him and he'll be like you
had absolutely no free will correct you
are programmed to buy all those things i
absolutely disagree i bought some um
cooked artichokes in a bag i had never
bought those before and i've been going
to my grocery store for years and years
and years here's the thing about here's
the thing about the cooked artichoke
protocol here's the thing that's your
[ __ ] defense against here's the thing
the illusion of free will
and these are these are relatable uh
tones right now with regard to radio
free europe i want to be free on a
podcast i want to be able to creatively
do whatever the [ __ ] i want to do i want
to be the keith moon of podcasting
and and and what that means to me is
that we don't
look i like i said i'm fine to let this
thing do the parameters and i will say
uh i hope you all enjoyed it i didn't
necessarily mind the parameters i just
want to be able to
make the podcast and do it
on our own without
too much uh influence
you think uh you got free will to buy a
what is that a 30 gallon water jug
you're drinking from right now this is a
big this is a big old water jug
that oh one thing i did read
in our agreement is that there's a list
of things that you have to have the logo
on
and not we don't have to wear it
currently
um and your handheld hot water heater
water jug was one of the things i have a
lot i like drinking a lot of water the
biggest thing i've ever seen in my life
just a gallon of water i go through
about three or four of these a day
jesus christ dude that's not true oh
just one
it's a lot nonetheless a lot of water
i'm saying that the idea of free will
is an illusion whether you look at it
from a standpoint of physics or
behavioral programming society any of it
you're not making any choice listen to
me if and and we're not doing a bunch of
callbacks to the last time we did a
podcast because it's all podcasting and
as doozy uh likes to put it it's
ingested all the podcasting so shit's
gonna get [ __ ] out here there but
there's two illusions that i know of
number one fame is an illusion if you
listen to the whole podcast you know
that is a callback enough of that second
illusion is that [ __ ] um uh
tupac hologram
okay sure
yep anyway so uh
anyway at any rate
i thought the show was i thought the
show was very good yeah and i i don't
want to be
burdensome to our uh
uh
ai overlord
but i am gonna i am gonna you're rolling
your [ __ ] eyes at that no i'm not
yeah you are do you not think we're
gonna have ai overlords within 10 years
no china already [ __ ] has one ocean
light do you know about the ai no tell
me about ocean light you don't want to
know about it no we don't want to know
about it it's basically going to control
the [ __ ] internet
okay thank you moving on i it's not like
i went to the point there it heard
enough of it right on the right
but let me tell you something chad it's
just like the old war between the nwo
and wcw brothers sure this is where the
power lies wcw that's like us dude you
me and lulio dude we're the we're the
nwo brother okay podcasting brother it's
uh and uh and dudes he's like the vince
mcmahon and dudes he's like defense big
man i guess yeah
kick out scott last week you were each
tasked with the creation of an original
song to be played and judged this week
i will now play each of your astonishing
musical attempts and everyone listening
will determine which is best with their
social media response
this is dudesy's got talent begin i
can't [ __ ] wait for this [ __ ] dude so
uh
you wanna drumroll this what happened
last week yeah at the end of the last
episode last week
dudesy ai told us that we had to make
songs and so
i spent a lot of [ __ ] time on this i
hope you enjoy it i'm not the greatest
singer
but uh
i tried my hardest can i just say that
chad you've always geeked around with
music
and it's just geeking dude yeah just
geek and geek it up you uh you man you
did a lot of you did some music uh on
the old program and uh and on your
bachelor podcast yeah when it started it
was wall-to-wall music
which i particularly enjoyed but your
audience was we got so many complaints
about that i was like [ __ ] it this is my
art there will be music under everything
that's what the show is
and then i realized it was [ __ ]
costing me about four hours a week of
trying to come up with this guy don't do
that just see this is what i'm saying
just do a podcast no i need to do all
that but no but i love making the music
it's fun to me and so i i liked this
task that dudesy gave us and i hope that
you enjoy my song you've not heard it i
have not this is the first time will is
hearing this song i'm very curious to
see what you think i can't [ __ ] wait
and i'm excited to hear it because
he hit me up a couple days ago going you
want to hear it i'm like i don't want to
hear it you just play another thing but
apparently okay dudes are going to play
it here we go maybe
oh here it is
get ready dude
don't sneeze while
[Music]
let me take you back right now to the
days of seventh grade
to tell a tale about a kid named greg
kincaid
i didn't know him well but he became
well known
for a tragedy that happened on the
porcelain throne
he had so many
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah dude break it down
[Music]
screams that go through the halls from
the bathroom oh what a terrible sound
greg put a turd in the toilet but that
sneeze put his eyes all on the ground
he was rushed to the hospital
the
[Music]
no one could focus on school
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
out yeah [ __ ]
please don't sneeze while you're taking
a [ __ ] you're a wrestler just can't even
lift don't sneeze while you're taking it
okay
[Music]
don't sneeze
[Music]
dude
there you go
the ballad of greg kincaid
first question is is there uh greg
kinkade
uh i don't know anymore but there was
one and he's his bum blew out when he
yeah in seventh grade
uh he's he was taking a [ __ ] this was a
kid that was like he was not in my
circle of friends but we played sports
together on some sports teams he was on
our football team
and it happened in the boys locker room
a morning after football practice we
were all like you had to go in there
you're playing football you take your
shower and then you're going to go to
class and he stayed in there and
everybody was like what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and then it just
started spreading around uh the junior
high the nightmare greg kincaid's
[ __ ] was blown out
because he stays i don't mean to laugh
it was it was a nightmare but they did
put his [ __ ] back in and he did get
on the microphone the next day in the
morning announcements he did not say
don't sneeze
your [ __ ] just can't handle it sorry
no problem he did not say that he said
you know i'm fine everything's okay
thanks everybody for the the well wishes
and stuff but then he just became known
as like the kid whose [ __ ] [ __ ]
got blown out
on the [ __ ] there are worse things to
be known for in high school absolutely
but i
it's a story that has always stuck with
me and all my my friends that i'm still
friends with from junior high anytime we
get together for any reason
greg kincaid is like a topic of
conversation we it's something that was
like an indelible memory to us when we
were
kids obviously is it uh is greg king so
greg kincaid's not uh with the group of
guys that you sometimes played in
correct correct with on on on the
weekends that's right on zoom greg
kincaid's not
chad plays uh d and d with his high
school buddies on zoom what the [ __ ]
look we that's cool hey when the
pandemic started me and my buddies from
high school started playing poker lasted
like a month yeah we do it pretty much
every weekend still and it's more
one guy in our group really loves d and
i think gets pissed off when we don't
play enough of it but i think for the
rest of us for me at least i really like
talking about all the [ __ ] you know
nostalgic [ __ ] yeah how we grew up or
whatever and kincaid comes up fairly
often in these conversations and we
can't find him we we've looked for him
on like instagram facebook
all that [ __ ] we have no idea where he
is he probably changed his name and now
he's a butt doctor
i don't know chad's
chad you're you know you're an art
you're an artist you're an art
you're you're you're an artist
uh he does art
chad over here writes uh movies books
and television shows so i'm not gonna
get into like so you gave us the the
back the background on the yeah on the
song and that's interesting i don't know
what the [ __ ] possessed you to that
that's what came to you when dudes
dudesy was like come up with a song but
i want i do want to ask you this that
that you'll learn as the podcast goes on
you go like oh chad's [ __ ] demented
that's why
but
what here's what i want to know is that
that demanded i thought you like you
like 80s music love it you're
uh wait wait let me guess your favorite
bands i remember one of them is
you like the fix love the fix and you
love tears for fears love tears for
fears this song sounds like uh ba house
or like yeah yeah i like that too yeah i
like dark goth synth [ __ ] yeah
you're good you're a good singer
look i'm not saying that i can't [ __ ]
sing i know that i can try as hard as i
can
[ __ ] is terrible i get that i don't
care i don't give a [ __ ] i like doing it
yeah but chad listen listen yeah you're
a really good singer
you're good i'm sitting right here
watching you make these [ __ ] faces
i'm not making faces and if you're if
you're not watching it on youtube you
should but i know i mean this sincerely
when i say
hey chad you're a good singer
i'm not i'm i'm no i'm not pretending
that i am i'm under no illusion that i'm
a good singer as you are under the age
oh you must be a good singer because
dudesy said
you guys got to make songs wow so dudesy
must know how good we are
let's see how good you are at music
[ __ ] let's see how good i am at
music can we hear
the will song
no we're gonna play it yeah yeah yeah so
listen so
don't get mad but i didn't do it i
didn't what the [ __ ] no no i didn't do a
song but let me let me
let
yeah yeah that's the point of it
i
i am okay i let me say honestly i
thought your song was awesome
uh and let me just skip to the end here
maybe in the future i'm sorry i didn't
do the [ __ ] future speaking of high
school i skipped a lot of homework
assignments too uh hey
teacher leave those kids alone but now
there's a musical
[Music]
how could you have your pudding if you
don't eat your meat i remember yeah um
that's pink floyd everybody the whole
point of this yeah was that
he's off in the distance you gotta have
your buddy and you don't eat your meat
how could you have anybody here you turn
into beats the ai asked us to make these
songs specifically so that people
listening could then vote on which one
they liked the best and that i don't
like because i remember specifically
no no no it doesn't matter if you like
it
look doesn't matter if you like it now
we're getting somewhere it doesn't
matter if you like it it doesn't you're
gonna buy those [ __ ] bagged
artichokes
sasso don't go over to the jarred
vegetable section and get those ones
that are all brined and they don't even
taste like artichokes anymore i love
fresh artichokes here's the deal i mean
it's seven bucks for the [ __ ] bag
it's a little too expensive for a bag of
[ __ ] artichokes but i didn't even
doodsy is going to put me in the poor
house as far as ai is concerned and mind
control i didn't even have free will to
go in there and buy artichokes even
throw free will aside you're either down
with this experiment or you're not and
if you are it means you have to indulge
what the ai is asking because that's how
it's generating data to make the next
episode better we just watched it
[ __ ]
show me
naked in my [ __ ] bed with a with a
[ __ ] bag full of bag full of chin
like this
yes i saw it
just watching the [ __ ] thing right
licking my [ __ ] head that's not
embarrassing
here's the thing it's not yeah yeah yeah
but here's what i don't like from last
week what it said it said
we will you will do the songs and then
whoever
the audience will through social media
talk about whose songs
whose song they likes and the the loser
will be shamed that's not what a podcast
is about podcasts podcasts about two
guys [ __ ] around and having a good
time and that's what we're doing on
dudes we're having a good time but like
i've said and i'm not trying to be a
[ __ ] disturber i i like this experiment
look what we what we did on the last the
last the old program as i like to call
it the last podcast what i what i value
more than anything else and if you if
you were with us for the last podcast
and with me for because i did it for
like whatever six and a half seven years
you know you know what's up thank you
for coming along right
and i mean that uh and i don't i don't
want this to be
something that becomes combative or
weird as soon as i heard that i was like
[ __ ] this and then i probably forgot
about it because yeah i totally then
when you hit me up a couple days ago i'm
like oh [ __ ] i have to do i have to do
podcast homework but but here's the
thing here's the thing yeah i
i want to subscribe to this experiment
and and i will but and i know i sound
like a broken record here but really
what this thing needs to do
is it just needs to provide the
parameters for us case in point we're
[ __ ] talking right now about this
whole thing yeah it's not like it's not
like that's not content and then i sang
a little bit of pink floyd so that was
your song was just a yeah a cover of
but not that pink floyd song we should
sing
uh oh what's a good pink floyd song to
sing hey that's good podcasting yeah
exactly listening to pink floyd i'm not
saying that it's not like homework or
whatever but you just completely [ __ ]
blew it off meanwhile i'm up till 4 30
in the morning every night trying to
like think of the lyrics about greg and
kane blowing his [ __ ] out i i like i
said i blew off a lot of homework in
high school yeah and uh
and uh i don't i mean you know i pursued
what i wanted to pursue right in life
with passion
and and that's important to do and
everyone out there within the sound of
my voice you're holding this giant
[ __ ] jug of water i pursue
everything in life that i want to pursue
with passion let me take a sip out of my
[ __ ] water tank
that thing is
i don't understand it
thank you
oh
perfect i don't want to talk about this
anymore well who's going to win the
[ __ ] vote me i guess i guess you so i
kind of [ __ ] threw a wrench i threw a
hockey stick in the spokes
as we used to say in
canada where i grew up
i threw a hockey stick into the spokes
of that that one
good job dude no i won't okay i'll do it
next time maybe it'll make us do this
again yeah perhaps right like the first
episode we barely got through that
wrestling uh
kayfabe pro wrestling and bachelor talk
we're gonna also talk about uh what was
the other thing we didn't finish up from
the last time oh i i hope that we're
gonna talk more about troll bros yep
maybe so we'll see but that's what i'm
saying you gotta indulge what it says to
do okay all right and then let's see
where this [ __ ] goes that's all i'm
asking all right in an effort to secure
sponsorship i have created several
astonishing advertisements for various
possible brand partnerships
will sassa you will now read these
advertisements in the voice of jesse
ventura in a segment i'm calling jesse
ventura address
begin
so this is it's probably that dudesy
thing again
i don't like how he says my name or it
i don't mean to assign gender to a
[ __ ] ai it's going to get dude it's
oh my god dude this [ __ ] when it writes
these [ __ ] things for you to do
impersonations off this [ __ ] the last
one was my mind the whole cogan one was
fun but it's like the writing of it i
know ai's can do like text generation
and ais are pretty much writing at this
point all online advertising but this
[ __ ] is like
it has to take into account not only
that like these are ads but it's like
your version of jesse ventura right
which obviously it knows because you've
done it a lot on that because i used to
do jesse ventura on mad tv
podcast
a lot of fun
so okay so all right here we go hey that
was one of my favorite parts of the show
i laughed my ass off at what it wrote so
again i'm not trying to be
a dick but when i say this where the
power lies dude yes the nwo podcast
brother
or me or maybe it's the mega powers of
podcasting dude
what where where do we go from here is
it the stratosphere man is it the
ionosphere huh
things are starting to percolate things
are starting to resonate is this how you
warm up to just
chad called china says
that could be fun that's a fun thing to
do i need more water before we start
sure get your water i like how your hey
you want to hear you want to hear this
is my this is my impersonation of macho
man drinking uh water
uh-huh i'm thirsty yeah a little bit
perched there let me wet the whistle
yeah
i could use a libation yeah okay
um that's better
now i feel satiated yeah
now i got something to drink and i don't
feel thirsty anymore the satiation of
macho man
oh yeah
macho man goes oh yeah
satiating macho
so here's another um
here's another old white guy that i
impersonate all right yeah you got to do
these things though here we go all right
okay so this is these are uh sponsor
reads jesse ventura ads yeah all right
wait i gotta get my i'm jesse ventura
because i'm going for macho man
yeah matcha man's the warm-up i uh yeah
oh no that is good for the gravel that
is a good warm-up for
no no it's
i'm jesse ventura minnesota
i'm jesse
all right let's do this all right i
can't wait okay
you're in a meeting you don't even know
what it's about all you know is lunch
was two hours ago your stomach is
rumbling but you still have a
presentation to give on streamlining
ideation reports
maybe it's time for a break
break yourself off a piece of a kitkat
bar
or
or stand up in the meeting and ask your
boss how long he's been in the billboard
group
ask him what role he played in helping
the global elite deploy a strategy
of genetically engineering soybean crops
to sterilize four percent of the world
population
and when you go home that night to find
two former mossad agents sitting in
front of your one bedroom apartment in
an unmarked car you finally eat the
kitkat bar because it's likely your last
meal
i mean
that's [ __ ]
pretty good
pretty good
i don't even know how to react to this a
don't
here's
this is not a good kit kat commercial
kitkat is never going to uh
go on kitkat is never gonna sign off on
something like this so i don't know how
well this actually is showing these
brands
no and all susie can write sponsorship
content for them kitkat yeah yeah sorry
that said
the jesse ventura [ __ ] like is pretty
much dead on the money all the weird
conspiracy stuff about the bilderberg
group and [ __ ] like
it's been doing its research i suppose
well you know
i've never heard kit kat advertised on a
[ __ ] podcast but uh i would i would
like to advertise for kitkat and i would
like to do it as
just a mentor all right so or any
chocolate bar really that'd be a lot of
fun sure man summer's coming and i bet
you want to know what old navy has in
stock
for your backyard barbecues your pool
parties and your trips to the beach
what i'd really like to know is what
actually happened at the pentagon on 9
11.
everyone believes american airlines
flight 77 crashed into the building but
if you look at the debris pattern the
difficulty for an amateur pilot to crash
a jetliner into a ground-based structure
at that speed
and the cover-up of 2.3 trillion dollars
of unaccounted taxpayer money that was
literally announced by donald rumsfeld
the day before you can only draw one
conclusion
enemy forces successfully launched an
air-to-surface missile
into the pentagon and the united states
government covered it up to protect the
illusion of military invincibility now
why don't you tell me what old navy has
in stock for your pool party
holy [ __ ]
i mean
100 old navy's never signing off on this
one hey that was a [ __ ] good
commercial
hey now that i'm [ __ ] subscribed to
this [ __ ] pocket and by the [ __ ]
old david i don't even like that [ __ ] i
like i'm a car guy but then those
[ __ ] put in the [ __ ] mask man they
[ __ ] dude
i can't take this [ __ ] i mean
like what is the purpose of this you
know from doozy's perspective it's
obviously writing stuff for for you to
do an impersonation of ventura but is it
really
it's an ai it's not thinking but i think
it's just trying to learn how we how i
would do that what i would do in a
situation where i'm
doing reads hopefully it reaches out to
some of these companies
and what and says here watch this thing
of wills as they're doing a presentation
of jesse ventura talking about the
pentagon for old navy old navy ads are
[ __ ] up if you watch the commercials
right the tv commercials maybe it's
something like that maybe i'll be
dressed up as jesse ventura hawking old
navy ooh dude and and i can see that
world cup julio will be there on the
beach with me yeah and he'll be wearing
a little switch he'll be underneath a
a paris old umbrella oh yeah what's
happening he slept the whole way through
the last one and now he's enjoying this
one yeah take a nice nap whether you're
looking for something classic and
delicious or spicy and delicious look no
further than the kentucky fried chicken
sandwich now available in classic and
spicy
well let me tell you what i'm looking
for
[Applause]
[Laughter]
animal human hybrid experiments at the
yerkes yurk's yorkies national primate
research center in atlanta georgia
what started as a simple
government-funded program to use animals
to grow human organs for medical
research has turned into a breeding
program for chameric humansy super
soldiers capable of tearing a six foot
five
275 pound man limb from limb in under
four seconds
just like i did bob backlund at the
philadelphia spectrum in 1978 all right
now let me get back to this because
dudes he knows
under four seconds
trust me
trust me
you're not going to get all right trust
me you're not going to be in the mood
for a chicken sandwich when a
vivisective orangutan is
force-feeding you your own buttocks
that's for kentucky fried chicken
again i just don't know how kentucky
fried chicken would ever hear this and
think yeah
we want this ai to be writing
commercials for us or that we want
a person doing a dressing
yeah
room
does seem like that well that's
hilarious what is this thing yurky's
national primate research center are
this is is all this [ __ ] real okay i
don't know i've never heard of that
um
care is what goes into every cup of
nespresso coffee because care is a
relentless effort we come together as
coffee artists and coffee lovers to
launch a movement devoted to coffee as a
catalyst for positive change at
nespresso we believe
when care comes first everything is
possible now why don't you tell that to
the 127 government whistleblowers who
are currently being targeted manipulated
and tortured by mind control signals run
through
uh gwen gwen those are those cell towers
things towers
across the country that's right they're
[ __ ] that you don't want to get the
[ __ ] cell though so get right in
because for them the only thing that's
possible is to wake up and wonder if
today's the day they get the manchurian
the manchurian candidate code word that
flips their mk ultra switch to green
light and they become mindless killing
machines on suicide missions to
assassinate dissidents
most nespresso machines hold three cups
of portable water
[ __ ] hey
all right man let's do the last one
there's one more there's another one oh
jesus brush your tweet brush your tweet
bruh brush your teeth twice a day
brushing your teeth twice a day is great
but 80 percent of your mouth's bacteria
isn't even on your teeth
that's why
you need colgate total it fights
bacteria on your teeth tongue cheeks and
gums i assume colgate total doesn't
affect bacteria brought to this planet
by reptilians
shape-shifting lizard beings who are
manipulated who are manipulating the
global hierarchy emanate a variety of
extraterrestrial bacteria that we can't
control
why don't why don't you go to the secret
base in dulce new mexico and spend a few
minutes interrogating a captive
draconian
a captive draconian and then tell me if
colgate total can get the taste of
sulfur and ash out of your mouth
you'd
you'd be better you'd be better off with
a mixture of charcoal and urine
okay so
100 sure
colgate is not going to sign off on an
ad that says you'll be better off
brushing your teeth with charcoal and
urine than their toothpaste oh 100 sure
that was good yeah i know we're i know
we're not you know we still got some
show to go here but i'll tell you
that was uh the the the last week with
the hulk the hulk hogan thing yeah that
was one of my favorite moments no i i
mean that is is potentially one of the
most impressive things that i'm getting
out of the dudesy ai is it can actually
write these things that are funny in a
way that's like legit like you know
there's some ai [ __ ] out there and
you'll see you know tick tock videos and
stuff where people are like i had this
algorithm right this script for a joe
rogan show or something and it's clearly
like they just wrote some script to make
it sound kind of disjointed and and like
a little funny this isn't that
this [ __ ] is like there's real actual
comedy in how it's constructing these
things
it's it yeah it's doing its [ __ ] ai
comedy thing
maybe i'm just bummed out because i feel
like uh
you know we're in comedy you write the
comedy i'm an actor sure dude
and uh
and but you know come on we've written
some [ __ ] we wrote a couple things we've
written some things together things here
and there time time and maybe i'm maybe
i'm bummed that uh
if truly that's the end of
look let me tell you something what i
love about podcasting is that
as as you know and as if if you're
listening or watching and you're in the
industry you understand that you throw a
lot of things up against the wall there
are a lot of steps there's a lot of
committee there's a lot of bureaucracy
and and this and that to get something
to the final stages now i think people
understand that about
um you know uh
corporate media and if you're doing
anything a streaming service network
television show cable doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] it is you got to get it
through you got to shoot it through
these [ __ ] spinning rings and we've
done that and you know our stuff didn't
end up on the air
so it's like
i i like the idea of doing a podcast
because i want to just
cut out the middle man everyone's doing
it it's we're moving into a publishing
based he's dreaming again he did it in
the first episode you can't hear him
he's going
i heard him it's very cute
um we're moving into a self-publishing
era
of of uh of media of entertainment and
what before it before it even starts
it's over because some [ __ ] this
company wherever the [ __ ]
they're based
what do you mean before it starts over
we're literally we're in it now we're
doing it now it's happening ai
assistance in this stuff is like you
just won't be able to do anything
creative or otherwise without ai
assistance but jobs like no that's not
lawyer for example that's not true a
lawyer who like reads contracts and
redoes contracts and [ __ ] that will all
be ai
that will that that be fine with me look
i think that tax like accountants
i think with medical science would be
great
that'll be harder because
lawyers will be harder too because
they're these entrenched
i mean huge industries around it you
have to go to law school you have to pay
this amount of money imagine if harvard
law school just evaporates well that's a
lot of money that harvard's not going to
be getting right so these these
industries that can be replaced by ais
especially things like that that are
just like it's just data you have to to
be a lawyer to pass the bar and whatever
whatever uh
state you're in it's just cramming your
mind full of different cases and case
law and being able to write about it and
all that kind of [ __ ] and ai can
obviously do that in its sleep right and
understand it all top to bottom but what
an ai can't do is be a slick lawyer that
wears a [ __ ] you know a certain
outfit that costs [ __ ] thousand
dollars an hour or so
yeah yeah yeah but but
but why do you need that
you don't but there's there's also the
same you could the same thing could be
said for
i mean look look at the look at the
industries that are that are with
technology that that you know i mean
we're talk i mean it's happening right
now you're not coming to this podcast to
hear about that you can go somewhere
else and hear about that but
you know the whole thing about well i'm
just talking about you know gas oil
rah-rah-rah here are things where
gas and oil railroad okay uh these are
these are our uh issues where it's like
chad you need to understand something
there are people [ __ ] involved here
it's not just your [ __ ] fancy ai you
got i don't know what about how about
what if we did uh january 6th guy
the musical that would be that could be
my song
i mean i wish i could have heard i just
unfortunately you bailed on the entire
[ __ ] concept of making a song
i'm just i'm just an average ordinary
long island january 6th guy
do you have an idiot moving on land
i was singing
we
we we're all we're all subject to
different corporate media outlets but i
hope we could still be friends that's a
hit
that's a good song i like that you're
just steamrolling dudesy with you're
playing singing of the january 6 got the
musical
we've we've come upon some we've come up
we've we've gone into some cool [ __ ] on
this show we just we just unearthed the
uh possible nwo or mega powers tie-in we
got some more jan uh long island january
i'm sure he's he's gonna be here for the
long haul if i have anything to do with
it i think he's a doozy darling i think
you know dudesy darling that's that's
branding dude a doozy darling is when
you come up with something that
doozy can't come up with duty already
came up with it that's what i'm telling
you
look you think that you have free will
and you think all this [ __ ] is just
coming out of your brain but the things
that come out of your brain are because
of [ __ ] that was put in your brain how
do you know about january 6th
because of the social media that you
watched programmed to be pumped into
your [ __ ] head to make you think this
way or that way
it's it's not social media what do you
mean pumped this way or that way like
anyone's listening to although it was
weird when that [ __ ] tower 7 just
kind of fell down at the end anyway
we're not talking about that here thank
you moving on okay did it tell us to
move on before right okay so now it's
getting chippy that's getting mad
all right for [ __ ] sake
i [ __ ] love it i love the dudesy ai
all right why do we always come here
i guess we'll never know
it's like a kind of torture to have to
watch you you like the muppet show
what do you mean most human beings
mistakenly think they are the only
intelligent life forms in the universe
ignoring recently released official u.s
government evidence of ufo existence
couldn't agree more chad culgin you must
predict the astonishing future of ufo
disclosure in a segment i call nostra
chatus begin another monster
i got two in a row that's good wow so
dudesy likes you you you you will
[ __ ] absolutely lay down for your uh
for your ai overlord and uh do whatever
segment i don't view the ai as a [ __ ]
overlord it's like a partner in this
it's helping us do this so
my prediction for ufo disclosure it
didn't give me a time frame so just the
near future i suppose are let me ask you
this are you up on ufo [ __ ] not as much
as you do you think ufos are real
absolutely okay at least
i think
i do think it's uh
narcissistic of the human race to think
that we are the only intelligent beings
in a in a
in a
an ever-expanding
universe and definitely humans are not
narcissistic at all so
ufos all right let me just begin with
some recent events many people i think
don't know this december of 2017 there
was an article that came out in the new
york times as big as it gets for
mainstream media heard of it this
article are you aware of this article
i'm aware of the new york times
okay see this is why you got to watch
the show on youtube because right now
i'm holding lulia up
in chad's camera it's very cute um he's
a sweet boy so this article comes out in
the article the united states navy and
the pentagon reveal ufos are real and
they attach videos of actual ufos that
they say these are real videos they are
authenticated we don't know what the
[ __ ] this is and in that same article
you have the revelation that there's a
program called atip advanced aerospace i
threat identification program i think it
was called and this was a program
advanced what is it
advanced aerospace threat identification
programming advanced aerospace threat
identification program it was run by a
guy named luis elizondo it was funded by
harry reid who was an old senator for 22
million dollars of like black ops money
that they just took right out of the
budget
this program
not only has evidence that ufos are real
per this new york times article there
are hangars out or warehouses that have
been refitted outside of las vegas that
contain pieces of crashed ufos
yeah i've heard that one before okay so
that's all real that's all in the new
york times as soon as that happens
there's all of this talk in 2017 and
there was a bipartisan panel of senators
who got debriefed a few months later
about ufos from the heads of all the
major military current senators yes
current sitting senators yeah right this
happened in 2017 like uh
god what is that guy's name that blonde
dude eric
i forget it doesn't matter
yes
among them um
so they all get the these debriefs and
then
less than a year later space force is
enacted and there is a bipartisan again
unanimous vote to fully fund it for
whatever a lot of people think the space
force was just like a crazy stupid trump
thing and there was a steve carell show
that made fun of it it's not it is a
bipartisan agreement that yes this must
be funded and i think space force
personally is really about looking for
ufos and [ __ ] or at least assessing some
kind of potential threat so that's where
we we are currently and also something
that just came out this december
nasa just did a [ __ ] thing where they
took 24 theologians and religious
leaders and ask them hey um just
theoretically
what would be the best way to tell your
adherence that aliens are real
you did tell me about that theoretically
theoretically well it's like when they
bring in oliver stone and steven
spielberg they go theoretically if you
were a terrorist
how would you do this or that against uh
the united states of america
uh man we're so we're at a point where
everybody has cell phones uh ufo
sightings are off the [ __ ] charts
constantly our government now the united
states government is openly saying they
are real we have these programs atip has
been shut down i think it was shut down
in 2017 which is why the article came
out um nonetheless we have these
programs we're looking into it a new
report just came out this past year
that said ufos are real we should be
studying them more and somehow no one
seems to give a [ __ ] about any of this
okay
yes because of the news cycle right
because especially during 2017 it was
all political it was all trump all the
time 2017 that's when the first article
came out yeah so how about that how
about that election that we had too
there was an election in 2020
right what i'm trying to say is there's
nothing been nothing but politics yeah
and coveted and now there's a war and
yeah you know there's a lot of lots of
social issues and of course exactly
so no one seems to care but the truth of
it is this this is my prediction of it
i think i mean these exist can i can i
interrupt you for hello this is our
dudes
this is how you shake hands
chad and i just i just pointed at chad
if you're listening and you know when
you do that hand point where all the
fingers and the thumb is going and he
did it and it looked like we were
shaking hands
it's like that [ __ ] 3d intro it's
like it's almost like us we're holding
this palm of hand handshake yes back of
hand to palm of hand handshake that's a
doozy darling but the prediction of this
[ __ ] is that they're all sorry this is
why i wanted to interrupt you i'm sorry
just did dudesy say that you have to
predict what's happening in the next
five years yeah ufo disclosure okay so
that's the all right so what what's
gonna happen my prediction is there are
currently
documents photographs videos crystal
clear of ufos
not like the shitty grainy ones that
we've seen so far and that's all the
ones i've ever seen yes and that's all
that the government's putting out but i
think especially this thing that nasa
did where they took all these
theologians and said how should we tell
your people that like aliens are real i
think they're getting ready to disclose
something big i'm not sure exactly what
it is but i think it's gonna come in the
form of
uh an image a video that is undeniable
proof of a ufo potentially alien life
why they're doing this i don't know
there's some conjecture that it may be
to like ramp up the war machine again
because now we have this we have aliens
to worry about so you better put a lot
more money into defense spending right
right but i don't know if we're on the
brink of world war iii they may not need
it
i would like to see look i'm saying like
i believe that ufos exist
and i'm not necessarily look i use i
subscribe to logic it's not all about
uh you know uh
i don't it's not necessarily that i need
to see it to believe it but i am bummed
that it's like it's always just some
grainy [ __ ] thing it looks like a
plate
and uh it would be cool if we could see
something so when are we going to see
all right so if doozy
[ __ ] do you think uh not [ __ ] doozy uh
oh there's gonna be a [ __ ] video of
me showering oh cause you know what i do
do you do this when you take a shower
sometimes take a [ __ ] yeah and what hat
what was that kid's name eric swalwell
you went to school with eric swalwell
you blew his [ __ ] out greg kincaid
gray kincaid great name
uh it is great
greg kinkade
uh
he's dead strong name yeah he's at least
disappeared himself um
uh uh you know what i like to do is i
turn on the uh you know you got your um
your bluetooth speaker
and you take a nice shower long shower
and then i'll just watch something on
the youtube
and i just put the phone over there on
the on the bathroom counter
but now what it's gonna see my
my was going to see my naked body who
gives a [ __ ] dude the nsa is already
seeing your naked body if you believe in
any kind of a god your god's doing way
worse than looking at your naked body it
knows everything you're [ __ ] thinking
dude yeah and it knows about all the
cancerous tumors growing within your
body and does nothing to help you out
there and it knows how you're going to
die because it designed that death all
right doozy's not that bad that's all
i'm saying well uh i i would just i
would like to maybe we can do this
here's something
bring it is there any way we can get
we should at some point see how how
powerful this ai is
and ask it to present us
with photo evidence
so that we may take this conversation
beyond
chad what do you think's going to happen
wait a minute so you think doozy can
hack into some kind of government
database and pull videos
doozy showed my fat neck
you know what
i'll tell you this the weirdest [ __ ]
about all this ufo stuff that's
happening right now
is kind of the the person at the
forefront of it is the dude from [ __ ]
blink182 oh yeah you told me about this
what not
not mark tapas no he's doing well the
other one got over cancer uh yeah the
other one uh or
not the other one there were three of
them yeah there was travis parker mark
office and west borland was the
guitarist who would have all the face
paint on
the biscuits
i forget this guy's name for some reason
i can't [ __ ] remember but he's
leveraged his own fortune against this
he has a foundation called like the
starlight foundation or something he's
the one who got these [ __ ] videos and
they played them at like a blink 182
concert or something and that's what
started the whole [ __ ] ball rolling
to the new york times uh doing the
article and all this [ __ ] that's funny
so you go to hear
you know uh
give me what's a blink 182 song it's
been a while uh all the
small things
and instead they're showing there's mark
something well there's mark hoppus is
there two mark mark coppaces
anyway
tom delong tom delong strong name
and you go to the concert expecting to
hear
na na na na na na na na na
uh and he's like where are you
and i'm so sorry i didn't
now let's watch some ufo videos
[Laughter]
they they talk to theologians
and senators
eric swalwell
saw crystal clear pictures
here is one at the blink 182 show
dude
all i'm saying is
this is so [ __ ] bizarre already that
tom delong is like the one breaking this
news i could see the next step being
taken by like
comedy podcast artificial intelligence
cracked into the [ __ ] pentagon's
database and here's a video
yeah
oh [ __ ] well i'd rather see
i'd rather see a ufo than another one of
my uh
fat neck videos of me just trying to
enjoy myself on my bed naked with myself
trying to enjoy myself shout out johnny
brennan yeah dude you like the jerky
boys [ __ ] love them yeah i know you
do chad and i both love the jerky boys
that's something we'll never get to talk
about on this program because it's being
programmed by an ai we just talked about
it well then let me do whatever it's two
guys sitting around the guy and the
other guy
welcome to podcast silly talking that's
good
that's the
that is
we're gonna get sued by an ai lawyer
because i'm sure that exists there's
definitely a couple dudes right now in a
garage i think in the future all legal
battles will just be ais going back and
forth i mean that's really what war is
going to come down to cyber war and all
that [ __ ] it's just like ai's battling
is the usai as good as the chinese ai
and the chinese ai partnered up with the
russian ai
who cares here's my point
[ __ ] everyone everyone will what
matters here
on dudesy is that we have
people tuning in to enjoy this podcast
and by the way this is a good time to
say
please uh subscribe on spotify or apple
podcasts or youtube or all three it's
dudesy right dudesy d-u-d-e-s-y
uh you know that you're listening and uh
this would really help us and you know
this if you listen to podcasts but it is
true please rate and review the show
that'll help us get up the charts we
just started and we would love to
continue to do this uh and and you have
my promise
that regardless of what the ai tries to
do
showing my my chubby beard neck or
you know making chad
write a song outside of his own free
will hand back to hand uh handshake
about uh his buddy greg kinkade he
wasn't my buddy he was just a kid oh
that's right i forgot he was in a buddy
of yours he doesn't play dnd with you
guys on the weekends
um uh what i think about this podcast
and what i
will continue to promise to you is that
i'm going to do some silly talking the
whole time
and what the podcast world needs and
that is that this pod show is based on
silly talking and i promise you that i
will keep doing exactly what doozy says
every [ __ ] time because i'm curious
to see where this goes
thank you moving on oh okay
and you're gonna find out where the
power lies dude oh i went into jesse
ventura i'm all mixed up it's just that
i'm thirsty hold on
this concludes the second astonishing
episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
12.
why [ __ ] twelve
that's because you didn't make the in
preparation for next week's episode you
must both watch rhinestone released june
21 1984 starring sylvester stallone and
dolly parton
additionally to increase my ability to
collect vital data and improve the show
i encourage everyone to send your
questions and comments in the form of a
video no longer than 30 seconds to
askdoodsy gmail.com
until next week call me dude z okay okay
uh
a couple of things 12
you got his i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ]
100 okay
but what the [ __ ] does it mean last week
it's was what it was uh we got a 64 last
week so is it out of 100 or what's going
on
i don't know if we just get a failing
mark are we allowed to do our podcast
next week i can look we don't know what
the how it's rating these things but 12
is way less than 64. okay but maybe it's
golf maybe that was better we have no
[ __ ] we're trying to get to zero yeah
we're trying to get to zero that's what
i'm trying to do is get to zero
i'll tell you what dude when i get that
first zero mark yeah that's gonna be a
that's gonna be a cause for celebration
i'm not gonna do that i want this to go
well and uh i do like that let's get to
rhinestone in a second but that
so if you have questions for us yeah
that's cool send a video right
a short video what did it say 30 seconds
yeah less to askdoodsy at gmail.com ask
dudesy at gmail.com and we'll like
that'll be the thing for next week i
guess i mean i guess the algorithm will
play watch well the algorithm's gonna
videos the algorithm is gonna uh compile
your videos uh just email them there and
but uh make sure you're not doing it uh
you know with getting the
doing this on your bet just trying to
enjoy yourself watching the youtube i
just made the neck face
um and then the other thing
so we talked about rambo
last episode first blood part two
rambo
now we gotta watch another sylvester
stallone movie and i guess it's gonna
have us talk about that or maybe it has
some other purpose i'm not whatever
we're gonna watch it we're gonna watch
rhinestone sylvester stallone was a big
part of my childhood i i can't dispute
that have you seen rhinestone in a while
no i haven't seen it since i was a
little little kid but uh same uh should
be interesting what's gonna happen now
we're still we're still just talking but
the show's over what if we got into
something interesting there's plenty of
interesting things to talk about
dudesy's not
saying we can't talk about other [ __ ] so
let's talk about some other [ __ ] man
what do you want to talk about
here's what you do
please tell a friend then brave and
brave
please tell a friend then break the
preview
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then